hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen mode
vorstellung die letzte vorstellung ist
ein wenig länger her ist einfach weil
ich jetzt nicht so viel zeit habe und
die schule zurzeit wir auch sehr sehr
heftig ist deswegen werden in nächster
zeit auch erst mal weniger vorstellungen
dem comic held mich bemühen dass da noch
ein bisschen was kommt aber ich will
wieder viel zu viel und kommen wir erst
mal zum thema uns was ist oder die
triebkraft modifikation wurde mir von
mehreren usern unter das letzte video
gesendet habe ich dann auch gemacht also
mich da mal so ein bisschen darauf
vorbereitet und ich wollte euch jetzt
mal zeigen was soll s hinzufügt ich habe
schon so ein bisschen was aufgebaut erst
mal ihr braucht dafür fort und ist das
dann einfach in die mods ordner rhein zu
verein ziehen auf der beschreibung ist
link ich bin wieder total
sprachbehinderte gerade in der
beschreibung ist in lenk das tutorial
einfach und wenn ihr da hier drin sein
und er drückt und dann hier oben habt
ihr zwei pfeile das sind die normalen
items sie alle könnte hier drauf gehen
dann hier auf treppen und sich alle trap
sachen diese drei sachen also tripwire
huck string und trap door also tripwire
seil und die falltür sind natürlich
schon dabei allerdings sind diese 61 neu
und hier ist übrigens der fehler dass
das nicht richtig angezeigt wird der
name zumindest das sind spikes also das
sind die spikes das ist ein dummy hat
also ein dummer kopf ein sehr
trickreicher kopf für dich eher sagen
gress covering ist einfach gras genauso
wie das passt sich halt eurem normalen
gras der umwelt an
magnetic test also eine magische also
eine magnetische die magische eine
magnetische kiste it-leiter fan und
japan heißt halt so gebläse sagen ich
mal gut
ich würde sagen ich zeige euch dann erst
mal ganz kurz die einzelnen sachen und
das was dann geschah
na gut ich könnte noch ebenso ein paar
sachen hier holen egal dass ich einfach
nach her und zwar den dummy hält crafted
ihr euch in dem er braune wolle dahinter
und lapislazuli darüber und jetzt will
ich erstmal herzen bett und zwar
brauchte dafür zwei runden sachen und
packte einfach den dummy hält drauf und
dann habt ihr hier so einen typen
den könnt ihr nicht bewegen den könnt
ihr allerdings schlagen aber die bleibt
immer auf der stelle kann jetzt etwa
wegschmeißen übrigens die schöne
landschaft hier sieht wollen ja immer
einige haben hier so oder ist der sieht
ich bin ich direkt hier gespräche
sondern hier also es ganz schön in der
hintersten dschungel glaube ich dass
justin dschungel
da ist es ganz schön und wenn ich jetzt
ein monster sporne wie zb ein sagen wir
mal ein skelett ja ok sollte eventuell
so und ich mach mal time and night sowie
2x bot die schießen letztem ich diesen
komischen typen ab und ich bin jetzt
quasi für die komplett nicht sichtbar
und die denkt jetzt dass ich der da bin
und kann jetzt ganz einfach töten
der hat 20 leben und der verspottet hat
quasi alle monster der liegt quasi
trickreich reihen einfach und entschied
sich gegenseitig ab ist witzig na ja
also es klappt halt wirklich bei allen
monstern außer bei warte ich töte die
man ganz viel mehr für mich kommt ein
bisschen so ist update liegt bei allen
monstern aussage der bewegt getötet seit
dem baum bis sommer wieder richten so
machen wir mal wieder teil des zdf
es kommt halt wirklich bei allen
monstern außer bei zombie zwei kombis
wollen halt menschenfleisch und nicht
das fleisch von ihm zum verrückten holz
copter und naja also die haben 20 leben
habe ich glaube schon gesagt und die
droppen einen damit beim tod deswegen
hatte ich demokrat noch beim inventar
dieser dummy hätte aus könnt ihr euch
dann halt wieder neuen machen da
brauchte dann nur wieder holz für und
daher kommen wir nun zum knaller also
dass es von feuerbach gerät hat es gar
nicht besetzt die gleiter heißt was sie
flammenwerfer irgendwie sowas
da musste ich ihr comstor umpacken also
das sind jetzt sieben cobblestone in der
mitte ein redstone otto beck bekommt ihr
einen leid tue und was dieser ego macht
habe ich mir schon in schalter geholt
ich hab ihn einfach mal so kann ich
jetzt drückt bekommt das feuer und wenn
ich das dann wieder weg mache dann
müsste das feuer auch gleich einfach
aufhören brennt natürlich immer noch so
ein bisschen und zwar kann man damit
ganz coole fallen bahn wartete zeigt
euch das mal ganz kurz hier einfach mal
ist gut dass ich das ja alles ein
bisschen aufgepasst habe heute
funktioniert das jetzt überhaupt an
jetzt sind nur die latte und zwar müsste
ich jetzt muss jetzt eben alle
miteinander verkabelt aber vista watt
freunde wir haben ja nicht so eilig may
spiele jetzt kein großes
produktionsstudio wo ich ja alles
vorgelegt kriege ich planen das
natürlich alles selber von daher bitte
verzeiht mir diese sachen klappt das
jetzt überhaupt ich bin nicht so der red
storm profi das wissen mittlerweile so
was ich mache das jetzt einfach so ein
schwein pakistaner drauf es klappt
natürlich nicht ich bin total das genie
liste gal aber so klappt's jedenfalls
und das schwein trend an und damit jetzt
ist der rest doch natürlich aktiviert
das ist sehr schön
also ist auf jeden fall dass man damit
ganz klima weg bitte das war damals ganz
coole sachen waren ganz coole sachen
bauen kann ganz cool fallen aber nicht
ohne grund ist es die triebkraft
modifikation also ihr wisst schon
trap volle kraft kraft dann tatsächlich
mit wirklich ein paar schöne allen
kräften wird übrigens bald auch für den
multiplayer verfügbar sein also dass er
da multiplayer ein bisschen was
anrichten können entschuldigung
so wartet jetzt kommen wir zur nächsten
sache und zwar magnetic jazz dafür
braucht ihr 7 auf codeplex dann in
meyrin ingots und darunter auch ein
rätsel bekommt er eine magnetische kiste
welche einfach hinsetzen und einen item
hier so hinwerfe dann wird das von der
kiste angezogen wenn ich das dahin wer
für funktioniert das nicht dass dein
werfe 15 das auch nicht aber wenn ich
das da hinwerfe funktioniert das also
das ist mal so ein radius von so zwei
blöcken oder so es bildet sich dann
relativ schnell auf seine kreisbahn wird
dann damit angezogen also wenn ich jetzt
die ganze items soliden schweiz ist ganz
witzig alles aufgesogen uns in
dementsprechend dann auch alle hier drin
stecken sich dann hier
ja also lädt das was da wirklich steigt
so dass die magnetische kiste ist sehr
witzig wenn ihr zb fallen habt wie zb
das mit den diesem dummy hält und dann
kommt der die monster hin und führten
damit die beziehungsweise töten sich
wenn's gut läuft am ende sogar selber
und dann stellt einfach ein magnetischer
kiste daneben oder auch unten bei einer
monster fall oder so und die sammelt
quasi alle items 1
das heißt wer dann in monster fall ist
sie als monster verbrennen und tropfen
die ganzen sachen packte er hat einfach
so eine magnetische kiste dann wenn die
ganzen sachen damit eingezogen so dass
ist die magnetische kiste jedenfalls
habe ich ja schon gezeigt ihr mann
präsident warum ich die alle absolut
demonstration und zwar fan finde ich
somit das aller geilste da brauche ich
jetzt mal gerade hier was auf so so so
habe ich auch noch nicht getestet wie
das so alles funktionieren soll macht
das war wirklich spontan
ihr gesagt ich habe keinen plan ob das
alles funktioniert die chance mal ganz
kurz ob das so funktioniert erzählt so
auf jeden fall erstmal nicht als er
natürlich ganze kisten im weg so wartet
das man gerade ganz kurz ein bisschen
wetter macht da hin wenn das ganze so
ein bisschen war jetzt ein bisschen
platz mal nicht so machen wir hier lang
kluge köpfchen unter euch werden schon
wissen was sich mit ihr zu bezwecken
will machen tun sein
das sind jetzt alle aktivierten die
dahinter natürlich nicht aber ihr seht
schon es funktioniert in der mitte
redstone jenny lokales amberg
funktioniert und zwar wenn ich mich hier
ein stellenabbau ist da schnell f5
drücken gott ich hab den kreis
vielleicht ein bisschen zu klein gemacht
das funktioniert gerade gar nicht so
richtig wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe
und noch ein
ich wollte euch zeigen jedenfalls man
kann damit wirklich so ein kreislauf
bauen ihr seht schon ein bisschen
aneinander vorbei ich hätte dir
vielleicht alle noch ein weiter nach
hinten bauen sollen aber wenn ich jetzt
so diamanten reinbringen online ich kann
ich das nicht zeigen das ist wirklich
viel zu stark ach mist ich wollte
eigentlich dass sie dann so ineinander
ihr seht dass also die werden dann
eigentlich immer so einer kreisbahn
daher geschleudert und so und fliegen
dann die ganze zeit im kreis und genau
das gleiche passiert mit mir auch also
ihr seht schon ich werde extrem schnell
wenn ich da irgendwie so rein laufe und
ja also items der sinn von diesen fans
des halters items spieler und auch vox
im film weggedrückt werden mops kann
diskutiert zeigen so hier die wird er
auch einfach ausgedrückt die sache ist
einfach mal dass das schwein eine die
ist ja gut ich war das ganze mal wieder
ab ihr könnt auch wieder weg gehen so
wir müssen unsere unseren normalen
der rhein ist so geil dass diese
schweine die provozieren ja wirklich
dass man sie schlägt indem sie einfach
nicht weglaufen wenn man sie schlägt
sondern sehr verwirrt rumlaufen ich
würde mal sagen dass es besser wäre wenn
die weg laufen natürlich für den spieler
an sich erst mal blöd aber naja ich
denke das was man realität so weiter
geht s pikes spikes habe ich mir schon
gesagt haben da komischen fehler und der
sinn von dieses bikes ist einfach also
getrachtet wenn die erstmal unten 3 1 im
nationalen der mitte zwei hoch an was
erinnert mich das wohl schreibt die
kommentare und wenn man darauf tritt er
erleidet man schaden wäre das keine neue
wegpacken das heißt wenn ich da drauf
treten die schaden ich weiß nicht ganz
kurz ich bin praktisch j ich gehe hier
drauf und er leidet schaden oder wenn
ich auch dagegen laufe gleich bin ich
tot also ich verliere wirklich immer so
ein bisschen schaden immer so ein herz
und die sachen kann ich dann ganz
einfach ab und dann hab ich die wieder
anti vielleicht roth
aber nein game mode 1 so kann irgendwann
ganz kurz hier beim dings zeigen im
schwein das feld dabei laut tod also
sehr geil auf jeden fall was man
übrigens auch damit machen kann zeige
ich euch gleich noch mal dachte ich wäre
wohl so also ja was soll ich dazu noch
sagen greift ein mops und spieler an und
items gehen darauf übrigens auch nicht
kaputt so jetzt kommen wir zum letzten
letzten sache gress covering und zwar
geht das kaputt wenn man da drauf läuft
also ich kann das nicht einfach so
platzieren
soll und welcher drauf dann geht das
halt kaputt nicht kriegt dann wieder die
sticks gecastet wird es mit unten drei
sticks und darüber gras wenn ihr euch
jetzt wo ich beim gras das ist einfach
wenn ihr mit der schere da drauf klickt
dann bekommt ihr gras ist mir auch noch
nicht so ganz geheuer dass es wirklich
funktioniert
aber naja das nimmt die farbe von dem
biomüll gras an ich habe jetzt gerade
kein anderes biomasse kein sumpf bio
oder soll ich euch das zeigen könnte er
hin aber dann will ich jetzt nicht so
weit fliegen
ich habe alles nur so oder institute
wäre sehr kulant berger und star wird
das sehr sehr geil aussieht
ich finde alles kalt ist ist ihr
mittlerweile glaube ich finde es einfach
schön ist im landschaften so jedenfalls
ist das sehr gern in verbindung mit
diesen gras mit dieses bikes und zwar
kann man einfach so eine falle bauen
indem man hier so dieses bikes sind tut
und da drüber platziert man kommt man
warte ich muss es ein tiefer bonn
regiert vergessen
so sah es sieht aus wie ganz normales
gras ist auch so aber es sind frühstück
für extra spaß so schweinchen läuft
daher kracht in die falle geht da unten
rein und stirbt also finde ich sehr geil
kann man seine sachen mitbauen kommt man
da noch nicht mehr übrigens raus ist ein
sonderfall weil die sachen sind ja nicht
genau ein bisschen kleiner finde ich
sehr sehr cool kann man auf jeden fall
coole sachen mit bauen
und ja meine lieben freunde ich würde
euch dann einfach sagen wenn euch das
viele gefallen hat wie ich sagen sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal
oder wenn es euch gefallen hat es hat
euch gefallen hat sich was beim nächsten
mal ein solch gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine positive bewertung freuen
da natürlich seine firma arbeitet sich
darüber zu informieren ihr könnt mir
natürlich auch weitere mods in die
kommentare schreiben
danke übrigens dass ihr mit diesem motto
diese modifikationen die kommentare
geschrieben habt weil die finde ich echt
cool werde ich definitiv ein bisschen
öfter mal anwenden wenn ich auf
ähnlichen stil
nein schon wieder raus so egal werde ich
definitiv irgendwann mal anwenden und
dann würde ich sagen ja
sie muss beim nächsten mal tschüss